hey gang
what day is that ending it's my birthday
it's your birthday again okay since it
is your birthday i'm gonna let you pick
whatever you want in the store the doggy
store and you will get it
anything
i think he just wants food
are you ready
let's go
[Music]
oh my god my dad give me the bag of
anything i touch is oh it says now it is
now
it'd be so funny if you actually knew
but you know i know thank you
pray
give him give him a small bit
it's his birthday
gosh my birthday give me a tiny bit
a salad what kind of dog eats salad oh
he doesn't eat it he spit it out
oh you get the trolleys
your eat your vegetables
he dropped that eat your vegetables
did eat it
well done edgar
all right we're here gary
what's your stride oh he's got his
tongue here
gosh i'm very cute
what's your strategy
oh
he's tired you're charging energy before
we go is that it what's your tongue in
stop it stop it put it back in i'm gonna
get demonetized
he's tired now again we got a mr beast
dish okay gary you got 60 seconds to go
into pets at home pick as many things as
you want what are you gonna do are you
gonna bring anything for your sister or
your family don't look at my cn
i'm scared i don't want to do this i got
too much pressure
oh by the way the wish charger update
it's great it's good it's still good
it works no one cares ferex okay we're
gonna change camera now because uh we
don't want to be told off so we're gonna
be sneaky all right we gotta be sneaky
out here
why are you so cute why do you
he knows something
are you excited again
he's so excited he knows
suddenly wakes up
you can't touch the motorbike he pooped
this is exciting footage
there you go come on let's go inside
okay
stop stop
okay we're starting
now
anything you touch
not me
go
go look it's me right there hilarious
okay anything you touch sugar
don't touch that no no we're not going
here let's get out of here that's
this is a hamster
no don't
okay we got the first one good job
wait i should bring uh something to hold
it with
he touched hay
no we're not buying the hay
it has to be dog related i hear that's
the rules made up new rule
all right there we go everything on the
floor apparently
all right it's christmas early good
choice
all right
you
want great
oh my gosh why it's so much on the floor
oh do not go near there yeah yeah yeah
that's too big for you
oh no
bro
stop i i gotta be able to carry you this
is not a mr b sweetie we need to get out
of this island
here here you go
okay
here come here
look
dental stuff you need that you need
dental stuff
okay
you need right there
come here here oh
hey guys here
yeah
yeah
oh another one
all right
oh what do you got over there oh these
are good too you like these
now these you like these i know you like
these there you go you get to you
all right what else
oh all right
what was that what is this
ew what is
this you stealing stuff right here
what is he doing i look away two seconds
nothing there was nothing
oh
good let's get out of here just get out
no
no
[Music]
nope
good there's a shield here
what are you doing
[Music]
this is cat stuff right over here again
you need some flexible joints out here
he's so confused
oh get no
no
you did not touch that
all right here we go
okay
this is where it gets dangerous
this is where the expensive stuff is
edgar actually needs like a
new no he does not
want that one no he doesn't well that's
kind of cute you can't reach it what are
you doing
this is too big for him okay he can get
a smaller size then sure so sorry i
can't take a picture with you oh sorry
mate
uh i don't do selfies anymore oh yeah
sorry nothing personal
i get it sorry okay i love your videos
oh thank you very much we're actually
shooting now with edgar is it ryder are
you feeling here i remember being like
sixth grade ages ago yeah you can film
oh thank you okay great when i was
watching your videos
oh [ __ ] nice old school thank you very
much that's awesome yeah shake your hand
yeah of course right yeah say hi to
edgar it's his birthday
we're doing a video where anything he
touches we'll buy for him love it
cheers we'll do it
all right there you go you got a lot of
fans how does it feel
oh he loves those should we help him
fresh
come on make your choice
hey guys this sign which one do you want
what is this
maybe
oh it is
do you want an egg are you interested in
any of these oh yeah that might be good
like intelligent stuff dog smart
are you smart again he doesn't want it i
kind of wanted to try it though come on
touch it again yeah come on touch it
yeah definitely
okay
no no
no
there's this
[Music]
all right do you want a new bed egg
here's your chance do not
[Music]
oh no
he's very what is this you can't know
close
that one
it'll be all right peggy do you want
this
[Music]
what is this it was a long oh you need
to buy a ball as well he's such a gentle
dog i didn't realize this look at him
you want you want it
was that
he does need the new one
is that a good size for him
yeah
that's pretty good i think it's a good
sense what do you think anger
do you feel cool
do you want to get anything for your
sister like a dog bed for her
nope
that's kind of cute okay for your sister
no
no
more dental stuff
there you go
[Music]
okay he hasn't touched it yet he hasn't
touched me no he hasn't do you want it
he has to be interested in it he has to
show interest
[Music]
fine
fine get it
yeah yeah
it's reggie all right how are we doing
so far
that's all right
okay okay we got cats section coming up
i feel like people like this
million soul
hey
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh look how cute okay hey what are you
doing
there you go for
oh he loves small balls can you touch
this
look how much he loves it
do you like anything do you like
anything thank you do you want this one
no
do you want it no
he wants a cat door okay
he needs some money
he doesn't want
no
stop some of the cat food okay i found
it okay whichever one you want
whichever one you want
he's picked it
he's picked his favorite it's not too
big for him he still is picking
i want all of it
what about these these are smaller these
are snacks too
there it is biscuits
and treaty bites
okay that's enough we're cut we're
stopping here
look what we found
edgar you have to
he has to get it
shove it
you're stuck on these okay again
he wants that one and that one
and that one no he didn't touch that one
okay
you get those two
we're done edgar you're done you're done
son how was that
great hi
apparently everyone in pets at home
knows
who we are they're really nice shout out
to everyone
how did that go in gary are you
satisfied with the results we're going
to go back and review now yeah
it's my birthday
where do you want to start do you want
to wear the hat oh that's so cute
you're adorable
this is
he loves it he loves it maybe for maya
man it's cute
all right what next
oh
oh okay
okay
okay wow
wow
okay you love dave
stop pretending he cared more about my
fingers well technically he didn't pick
that one so janet edgar here spanking
okay what about this you love these
ziggy
you love the donuts
yeah
you love the donut
yeah yeah that's not that day i got a
doughnut and i got a date that could
donate
yeah
fresh birthday diaper
see we could have just spent like one
pound and he would have been happy like
i left it over there
[Music]
oh something more interesting
this is what they give you at the vets
and we're always like you can't bite
[Music]
surprise
it's too big for you
there you go
are you satisfied
yeah give it to your sister as well
edgar loves these right
he goes a bit psycho with these i don't
know if it's a good idea okay
psycho
wow he loves his son okay
oh he wants these how about we try out
this if you want those so badly it's a
filming maya
it's edgar's video oh look this is kind
of nice
okay so you just have to flip back all
right you can do this again let's see
how big your brain
really is
okay
go
he can smell it
come on you can do it please please
look
yes
come on
you almost have a brain come on
come on
no
[Music]
he's struggling
bless him she would just give him i feel
bad it's okay you're trying and that's
you tried your best and that's sometimes
all that matters
okay now try again
[Music]
oh he's so close
you're so close okay all right you're
done
we got this for you you picked this
great sense of fashion edgar oh this is
massive well you picked it now deal with
the consequence
wow so stylish you look
like look like a 50 year old man who
hates life
oh you did it you did it duck dead guy
you're so smart you're so smart you did
it
so proud of you
yes
let's go
this one is easy if you can't do this
boy
see
you just put a treat underneath is that
it he loves these snacks that's good
because i think they're happy
it goes there
it goes here
and he goes here now
exercise your dog's mind reduce boredom
and destructive behavior strengthen the
bond with your dog okay okay our bond
can be strengthened
come on
think about our bond
he's already given up
our bond is broken do you remember this
do you remember hey
do you remember think of the bond
why are you so gentle what's going on
use your brain thank you thank you again
now you're at now you're asking me i
want you to take action affirmative
action
you did this one this one is impossible
come on
okay
yes duke yeah again
maya do you want to try the intelligence
test
you want to try the intelligence test
everyone how much smarter you are
which one was that
i can't do the
i can't what
oh
this one
oh sorry
[Music]
you're so smart maya you're the smartest
dog in the whole world
good job maya you're the best
we love you so much maya you're so smart
you're so good
yeah
[Music]
shane shame on you
i'm kidding it's your birthday hey you
gay
ice muffin
sick
okay
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
how are they supposed to eat this
[Music]
relax
oh my god oh no
oh take it easy he's been biting
everything but the cupcake
[Music]
oh my god
he's an actual psychopath hey hey hey
she's still working that puzzle line
he doesn't care about anything anymore
he's peaked in life
we've got to find something more
interesting i get wow
edgar wow
okay i go wild
have your wow
[Music]
okay
take a while
like a while
okay
we did it
i feel like we just exposed our dog for
being like a psychopath
i'd get wow oh that's huge
yeah
smoking a fat one
hell yeah oh you gotta fight for this
one
[Music]
i feel like this is actually good for
his teeth
[Music]
okay here you go
[Music]
and well everyone that is edgar's
birthday happy birthday to edgar
we proven that he doesn't care about
anything except food who would have
thought
and he's not very smart either maya
however
she's still working on that puzzle
if you enjoyed this video leave a like
subscribe for more video and uh see you
next time i feel like if i take this
away from him it's gonna go crazy what
do you think okay
yeah we're gonna take that away from me
now sorry we'll take a break bye
everyone i'm a nice dog i swear i just
get quick
you had it in your mouth
this whole time okay bye